yeah well when I was in college it would
have been 1996 or 1997 I found online
some places where you could download the
music files that were pretty reasonable
quality for how big they were and this
was something that I had played with
before like in high school and and never
got really never got that whole sort of
CD quality sound out of the computer
before so when I when I found these it
was pretty interesting and so I started
playing around with it and one of my
friends in college at the time started
making a Mac mp3 player and on Windows
there was there were a couple pieces of
software available but they were kind of
limited they didn't really have a good
experience when you were listening to
music with them it was sort of very
functional and that like hey it's
playing it back but there was very
little of the sort of environment that
actually made listening to music on a
computer different from listening to it
somewhere else
things like you know showing
visualization being able to seek
randomly being able to build playlists
all of this sort of stuff that's very
commonplace in music playing saw for now
so so my friends started doing a Mac
version of the software called the Mac
amp and I hadn't really done very much
programming for Windows and Windows 95
had been out and it was starting to be
used by a lot of people so I figured hey
this would be a good way to learn how to
program windows application software and
so I made when I
I was pretty gradual there was an IRC
channel that I was hanging out on and
had friends on and these were people all
over the world who would just hang out
and talk about random things it's kind
of like Co many online communities are
an app but and so you know I I posted
early versions and people would play
with them and they like hey this is good
and you know it should do this it should
do that and so is this gradual thing of
people were starting to use it and
giving feedback and as that happened
like you get like people get excited by
it and they tell their friends and it
sort of grows it grows in its own way
that way which is very exciting but it
kind of happens over a long period of
time so you you know time goes on and
and each day isn't really that much
bigger than the previous so you don't
really notice it that much
I tunes probably started out very
similar to Winamp other than some
obvious differences it was acquired from
from another company but I think since
then it's probably then it's been
designed a by people who actually
weren't the programmers on it so you'd
have people making decisions who don't
even know how those those things that
are decided and you have to get
implemented which is often a mistake and
then also I think it's just been very
dumbed down like when working on went
out we always tried to make things
straightforward enough so that someone
who didn't who wasn't very technical
could use it and not be confused but
also exposed tons of power so that if
someone wanted to just completely
customize it to be exactly their own and
change the behavior to be what they
expected they could do that of course
iTunes is very much you fit into the
iTunes mold that's just how it works